i was hoping in this game wouldn't you
know do this to me anymore now that i
played it so many hours but
it still does it doesn't
doesn't stop getting scary it's so
annoying and the thing is when i log in
now when i play select and play
that monster is gonna be there behind me
and it's gonna i gotta start running and
it's gonna start chasing me
and i knew it i had to have something
that wouldn't you know
something that made me wanna continue
this play playing this game because
right now as it is now right now there
aren't many reasons for me wanting to do
this
so i do come prepared
now i gotta click continue yeah
i'm gonna pause it right when it goes in
it's going to be so [ __ ] horrible i
just uh
sitting in a dark room with headsets
phones on there that was a great idea
[ __ ]
load already [ __ ] i don't want
to hear that moaning again oh oh oh okay
okay i'm gonna since he's gonna shave me
i don't know if you guys can hear it
since it's gonna chase me i am gonna put
on some fitting music for it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh
oh my god that was still horrible
i don't wanna carry on
oh my god
turn this [ __ ] [ __ ] down
i didn't think he was gonna be that
quick